un détour par le Musée d'Art Moderne de
Paris qui expose le cri du norvégien
Munk sa toile la plus célèbre beaucoup
d'autres œuvres sign l'artiste sont
aussi présentés elles évoquent toute la
souffrance de Munk ses angoisses Marie
clertière Frédéric
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Bobin au fond des yeux d'Édouard Munk le
désespoir la détresse son tableau le
plus connu le cri
le peintre nous livre les angoisses de
l'âme moderne en inventant une
expression de l'urgence un art dit-il
qui naîrait du sang et du cœur l'amour
la maladie la mort la mort de sa mère
puis de sa sœur qui le marque à vie et
blesse sa relation à la
femme il y a deux types de femmes dans
l'exposition il y a y a il y a
l'évocation de sa sœur de sa sœur à
travers la
mort la maladie et are sœur également
qui est assez spectrale donc sont des
rapports très affectifs et au fond de
tendresse tu et caché et d'autre part
effectivement la femme qui elle est
assez débretée triomphante de l'homme et
dans un rapport très prédateur comme ça
un petit peu anthropophage par rapport à
l'homme qui lui est toujours tout blanc
alors que elle est est
flambante
le couple la jalousie la maladie la mort
des thèmes qui reviennent inlassablement
jusqu'à
l'obsession mais avec le temps sa
palette devient de plus en plus
lumineuse sa technique plus audacieuse
et plus fluide d'une grande
[Musique]
modernité à la fin de sa vie dans ses
autoportraits solitaire et malade il
jette une lumière crue sur l'angoisse
existentielle c'est l'attente de la
mort avant de refermer ce jour